[Applaudissements]
effectivement bonsoir a tous déjà alors
ici on est là pour combattre les
préjugés
rien de bien méchant donc déjà premier
préjugés que je vais arrêter qui sait ce
mec de l'est qui vient nous parler du
dark web
rassurez vous tout va bien on va parler
de blocs chaîne et bitcoin sous un bel
aspect le premier aspect ses vêtements
le titre de mon intervention c'est
bitcoin des blocs shine émancipation
numérique
alors effectivement la question c'est
celle là
l'agglo chain un peu tout le monde en a
entendu parler récemment surtout si vous
êtes un fameux rapaces financiers comme
on a vu en intro vous avez
nécessairement vu passer des blocs
chaîne quelque part donc je vous ai fait
un petit petite sélection des titres de
journaux qu'on peut avoir ces derniers
temps sur la blogo chaîne pour qu'on
comprenne un peu l'euphorie générale
dans laquelle on est les économistes et
donc pas un journal qui a tendance à
faire dans la caricature au sérieux en
parle comme de la machine a confiance
qui va révolutionner le monde on à la
tribune en france qui en parlent comme
de l'invention la plus importante depuis
internet
rien que ça vous avez deux ouvrages en
émis 1 mais il y en a plein d'autres qui
vous parle de ça comme d'une révolution
qui va changer le monde l'argent le
business donc là vraiment on est à deux
doigts de comparer ça avec l'invention
du feu du sabre laser c'est comme vous
voulez mais globalement tout le monde
est d'accord tout le monde est d'accord
c'est une révolution
problème on personne ne sait pourquoi
c'est embêtant on va on est en train de
vivre on va vivre une révolution mais
personne ne sait pourquoi et on arrive
souvent dans une situation qui est la
suivante que je montrais dans la petite
bd qui est devenu assez emblématique
dans la communauté
vous avez un patron qui va voir son
développeur qui lui dit il faut qu'on
construise une block chaîne aux
développeurs il ya déjà eu la situation
sur l'intelligence artificielle sur le
big data sur l'internet des objets etc
donc il sait que selon son patron n'a
rien compris à ce qu'il a dit donc il va
lui poser une question absurde pour
vérifier si la raison donc on va lui
demander de quelle couleur vous voulez
votre blog shane ce qui a à peu près
autant de sens que si je vous demande
mais vous préférez facebook salées ou
sucrées
ça n'en a aucun ne cherchez pas et donc
le patron ne se démobilise pas et lui
dit mauvais move parce que ça a plus de
ram a plus de mémoire
donc là on est vraiment sur un stade
assez dramatique et pourquoi on en est
arrivé là parce qu'en fait la blague
chaîne est devenu la solution mais
généralement quand on parle d'une
solution on a un gros problème au départ
et en fait on a oublié le problème pour
moi aujourd'hui je vous parlais blocs
chaîne et bitcoin certes mais pas tout
de suite
d'abord on va parler du problème initial
qui est résolu par vite connu et la
bloque cher et donc si on parle
aujourd'hui du problème initial on va
parler d'argent
généralement j'ai pas trop de mal à
mobiliser les foules sur ce sujet là ça
intéresse tout le monde
tout le monde a de l'argent plus ou
moins on en gagne on en perd tous les
jours plus ou moins également si je vous
sors par exemple un billet de 10 euros
qu'est ce que c'est c'est de l'argent ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que j'ai une
valeur de 10 euros dans l'ain cette
valeur de 10 euros
elle a une valeur 10 euros pourquoi
parce que les commerçants l'acceptent
parce qu'on est tous d'accord sur le
fait que ça vaut dix euros donc par
exemple aujourd'hui avec 10 euros je
peux obtenir des biens et services en
échange par exemple au cours actuel je
peux avoir une soixantaine de pain au
chocolat 10 15 centimes pièce mais
évidemment cet argent d'une sortie dans
ma poche
est ce que il m'appartient vraiment là
c'est la question que je pose est ce que
l'argent même que vous avez dans des
comptes bancaires aujourd'hui il vous
appartient vraiment
évidemment si vous posez la question
c'est un peu orienté on va voir que mon
pas forcément et pour ça on va faire un
petit voyage on va aller à chypre une
bien belle île de chypre île
paradisiaque un peu plus d'un million
d'habitants un pib par habitant entre 25
et 30 mille dollars par an donc ça va
des chiffres honorables
c'est pas le haut du panier mais c'est
pas non plus dramatique et bat chypre a
un problème
hyper original vraiment sont les seuls à
l'avoir c'est la dette publique
personne d'autre si ce problème est
évidemment la dette publique de chypre
et bat en 2,95 à 2006 2008
on est globalement autour de 50% bon ça
va c'est pas dramatique surtout vu les
temps qui courent et puis il ya une
crise pour ceux qui étaient dans une
grotte en 2008 il ya eu une crise assez
importante qui fait en ce qui a fait que
à l'économie chypriote s'est retrouvé
beaucoup plus endetté qu'elle ne l'était
avant et donc en l'espace de quelques
années on est passé de 50 % à 100 % a
plus que 100% et donc en 2013
petite crise chypriote où les banques
chypriotes se retrouve à devoir
rembourser de l'argent qu'elles n'ont
pas donc évidemment assez gros problème
mais elles ont une idée de génie vous
allez vous demander pourquoi elles n'ont
pas pensé plus tôt
ces résumés dans cette petite
illustration que je montre juste après
génial les gars on va pouvoir se servir
directement sur les comptes en banque
génial champagne c'est à ça a l'air
d'être une caricature mais c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé 1 donc on
rigole 30 secondes et bien fait on se
dit merde moi aussi j'ai un compte en
banque à chypre 2013
les banques qui étaient endettés se sont
dit bah on va prélever 10 % sur tous les
avoirs supérieurs à 100 mille euros 1
pourquoi pas bah oui on ait accès donc
voilà c'est à nous maintenant pourquoi
elle peut faire ça parce qu'aujourd'hui
justement votre argent et sur des
comptes bancaires et sur des comptes
bancaires et qu'est ce que c'est un
compte bancaire aujourd'hui globalement
c'est une série 2 0 et 2 1 tout est
numérisé et donc à partir du moment où
c'est numérisés vous croyez que c'est
votre argent
pas vraiment en réalité c'est l'argent
de la banque et puis de temps en temps
voulu demander l'accès à votre argent et
donc ça change complètement la
perspective donc là on commence déjà un
petit peu à douter
est ce que vraiment c'est mon argent il
ya d'autres exemples je n'ai pas tous
les faire mais globalement vous prenez
la grèce prenait l'ukraine l'argentine
ou l'inde
il ya deux semaines ans était pas il ya
trois ans les deux semaines l'inde c'est
le gouvernement qui le 9 novembre dit
bah on va démonétisé 86% de la monnaie
en circulation
voilà merci vous avez jusqu'à demain
c'est pas une blague c'est vraiment ce
qui s'est passé
donc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire tout ça
ça veut dire que globalement votre
argent il vous appartient plus voilà
vous avez la réponse à ma question
pourquoi parce qu'on veut que tout soit
dans des comptes c'est la guerre au cash
qui aujourd'hui utilisent encore le cash
comme moyen de paiement primaire en tout
cas principal plus beaucoup de monde et
ça en fait on s'en aperçoit pas trop
mais c'est un petit peu un danger et
c'est une tendance qu'il y a dans pas
mal de pays on sait pas que les pays en
développement si vous prenez les
bouteilles en les pays de l' ocde sont
généralement bien plus en avance
là-dessus vous prenez la suède est
généralement le chantre du
social-libéralisme du nord et ses bas la
suède 80 % des achats se font sans
liquide
qu'est ce que ça veut dire concrètement
ça veut dire que si demain vous allez à
stockholm et que vous prenez un taxi un
bus vous avez dans une petite boutique
c'est pas que vous n'utiliserez pas de
liquide c'est qu'il le refuse tout
simplement pouvait pas payer en liquide
dans un taxi n'ont pas d'égal londres la
même chose j'étais il ya encore quelques
semaines je vais dans un bus je vais
acheter un ticket en cache pas possible
de solutions continuer à pied ou sortir
la carte bancaire et donc j'ai continué
à pied
donc ça c'est un petit problème alors
évidemment numérisés l'argent ça à plein
davantage va pas se voiler la face on
peut on peut grâce à ça va éviter de se
balader avec trois tonnes de pièces et
de billets dans sa poche
on peut payer directement le bon montant
lorsqu'on est à la caisse
ça nous évite d'attendre dix minutes
d'avoir le change non plus envoyer de
l'argent partout dans le monde et était
rien à plein des avantages mais ça à
quelques petits inconvénients qu'on va
voir tout de suite mais rassurez-vous
trois fois rien alors première fois rien
l'exclusion financière de la moitié de
la population mondiale
c'est pas grand chose évidemment on a
tendance à l'oublier parce que en fait
dans les pays ocde bas tout le monde un
compte en banque
globalement on regarde autour de soi
tout le monde raconte d'ailleurs
généralement c'est parfois une
obligation légale mais dans les eaux
reste du monde et si on prend le monde
dans sa totalité ses 53 % des gens qui
n'ont pas de compte en banque et qui ont
accès à aucun service financier primaire
donc ça veut dire 3,5 milliards de
personnes c'est pas rien du tout à tous
ces gens là on va leur dire très
gentiment on fait la guerre aux cash
donc désolé vous pouvez plus utiliser de
cash par contre n'hésitez pas à passer
par ce compte en banque on vous interdit
d'ouvrir
ça va être très drôle d'aller voir le
l'éleveur sud africain le fermier indien
d'aller lui dire non ouvrir ton compte
en banque mais tu peux pas deuxième
problème deuxième fois rien yes we can
pourquoi parce que si la banque qu'elle
détient votre argent et que l c'est ce
que vous faites avec globalement votre
vie privée est réduite à portion congrue
comment 10 à 0
la banque c'est tout ce que vous faites
elle cède tout ce que vous achetez tout
ce que vous vendez donc vous aurez beau
essayer de le cacher de toute votre
force la banque c'est que vous achetez
des cds justin bieber et c'est ça qui
est dramatique troisième fois rien une
intermédiation dont personne ne veut je
m'explique vous aller à la boulangerie
aujourd'hui vous payer deux euros au
boulanger la boulangère il reçoit deux
euros en cash très bien merci au revoir
vous utilisez la carte bancaire eba vous
ça vous change rien c'est même plus
rapide d'ailleurs vous sortez plus
rapidement de la boulangerie mais lui ça
nous change tout lorsque lui reçoit pas
de zorro vie va recevoir 1 90 à 95
pourquoi il est il humain au milieu on
voit pas un mec qui s'appelle
prestataires de services de paiement qui
s'appelle bank l'établissement de crédit
visa mastercard y en a beaucoup qui vont
prendre une petite commission mieux et
puis il aura pas son argent tout de
suite il l'aura dans 30 jours 60 jours
ou 90 jours
jamais on sait pas donc ça c'est un
troisième programme qui est assez
important si je vous disais que tous ces
petits problèmes là trois fois rien donc
on pouvait les résoudre en ayant quand
même la numérisation de l'argent vous
voyez venir on revient sur le sujet
c'est bitcoin qu'est-ce que ça évite que
non je tout de suite je désamorce n'est
pas l'argent du dark web je sais quoi
etc
bitcoin on va revenir à la dessiner des
définitions principal de son créateur
c'est à dire c'est un peer-to-peer
électronique cash system système est
rappeur d'argent liquide numérique et
c'est très important se cache argent
liquide numérique lorsqu'on n'est pas
sûr du compte en ligne on n'est pas sûr
de la banque en ligne on n'est pas sûr
de la carte de crédit en ligne sur de
l'argent liquide numérique
donc ça veut dire toutes les propriétés
de l'argent liquide s'est ouvert s'est
décentralisé ses pairs à pairs c'est
sans intermédiaire c'est sans frontières
c'est résilience et respectueux de la
vie privée etc etc tous assez vite
collègues et avec bitcoin pour la
première fois on arrive à créer de la
valeur numérique un jeton de valeur
numérique c'est à dire c'est pas un
titre de dette
c'est pas un droit d'accès sur un compte
que quelqu'un a quelque part et parfois
ils vous donnent l'accès c'est de la
valeur numérique et ça c'est important
parce qu'on dit de la valeur numérique
d'accord très bien aujourd'hui c'est
quoi la valeur numérique de bitcoin un
bitcoins et 700 euros
[Musique]
ça va ça veut dire que je n'ai pas un
bis
corinne j'ai un peu moins d'un mille
tonnes cédées visible jusqu'au
millionième donc pas de soucis mais ça
fait beaucoup d'argent
qu'est-ce que vous permet de faire
bitcoin en réalité ça vous permet de
court circuiter le système aujourd'hui
un virement c'est comme ça c'est à dire
que vous donnez pas un virement à
quelqu'un vous dites à votre banque
d'envoyer à la banque
généralement il ya une chambre de
compensation au milieu de terrain mais
je vous la fait courte à l'autre banque
qui doit à prévenir votre ami qu'il a
bien reçu quatre jours plus tard votre
argent biscayne arrivée vous dis non non
non vous n'avez pas besoin de tous ces
gens là moi je l'argent votre ami le
reçoit directement pair-à-pair en dix
minutes
comment ça marche tout ça on retombe sur
nos pattes la bloquer la blague chaîne
sait qu abbas et rien d'autre que la
technologie qui va nous permettre ça qui
va permettre bitcoin évidemment je vais
pas m'arrêter là j'ai détaillé un petit
peu qu'est ce que la prochaine
imaginez-vous expérience de pensée
imaginez vous un cahier jusque là tout
va bien
un cahier dans lequel vous allez écrire
plein plein plein de transactions en
l'occurrence toutes les transactions qui
ont été effectués en bitcoin donc on a
par exemple ce cahier laon j'écris des
noms bien évidemment fictifs ont rien à
voir avec l'actualité
vous avez ras bruno qui donne à nathalie
tauziat d' qui donne à nicolas
une fois que c'est dans ce cahier et
bien ce cahier il est réparti
ça c'est curieux parce que d'habitude on
stocke quelques parce qu'ayant hall
verrouillant veux pas qu'on n'y touche
pas là si la le cahier il est réparti
tout le monde là tout le monde là tout
le monde peut écrire dessus donc là les
deux questions car avec tout de suite
c'est mais si tout le monde peut écrire
dessus c'est le bazar qu'est ce qui se
passe
la deuxième question c'est si jamais il
ya un malfaiteur pardon si jamais il ya
un malfaiteur qui arrivent et qui dit
moi je vais effacer une transaction où
je vais rajouter des transactions
frauduleuses comment on fait et là votre
cahier il faut considérer qu'il a un
système de validation qui est un petit
peu particulier
comment ça se passe sur ce cahier là on
ne va pas validé transaction par
transaction en valider page par page et
ça change tout parce que vous pouvez
faire de l'archivage périodiques
séquentiel toutes les 10 minutes une
nouvelle page est ajouté comment on va
choisir quelle est cette page en réalité
on va laisser tout le monde faire ce
qu'il veut avec sa page moi je par
exemple imaginons qu'on est à la page 5
on veut passer à la page 48 tout le
monde dans le réseau est en train
d'écrire sa propre page 48 avec des
transactions qui l'a reçu même des
transactions qui dont il est
l'observateur dans le réseau qui n'ont
rien à voir avec lui il va faire sa page
est un algorithme de consensus ça
s'appelle comme ça qui va déterminer
aléatoirement quelqu'un dans le réseau
qui va avoir le droit de valider sa page
qu'est ce qui fait une fois qu'il est
désigné il soumet sa page au réseau le
réseau la regarde et dit est ce que
toutes les transactions qu'il ya dessus
sont intègres
oui non ils ont tous le cahier donc ils
peuvent remonter tout l'historique pour
savoir si de l'argent dépensé n'a pas
été dépensée avant etc etc
et une fois que c'est fait on lie la
page on passe à la suite
quel rapport avec la bloque chaîne vous
me direz parce que là pour l'instant on
est toujours dans l'expérience de pensée
bah c'est très simple votre cahier c'est
votre bloquerait tout simplement les
pages ce sont des blocs et la reliure
c'est une chaîne les pages ce sont des
blocs la reliure c'est une chaîne voo
numériser tout ça vous avez une longue
chaîne un bloc avec des transactions
dedans on passe par l'algorithme de
consensus dont je vous ai parlé le bloc
c'est votre page il est validé et
ensuite répartis sur le réseau si vous
voulez modifier quoi que ce soit ça va
être compliqué parce qu'il faut aller
modifié sur l'ordinateur de tout le
monde est donc là évidemment j'imagine
un peu de déception parce qu'on vous a
vendue la technologie la plus
sophistiquée du monde qui va remplacer
le feu le sabre laser et on se retrouve
avec un cahier magique
évidemment je comprends votre désarroi
cependant sous ses airs un peu chétif
vient de vous présenter la seule manière
qui existent aujourd'hui d'échangés de
la valeur sur internet en pair à pair
vous allez lire l'opérateur ça existe
déjà
certes ça existait des torrent etc je
peux vous envoyer une photo en torrent
très bien on a listé en réalité je vous
l'envoie pas cette photo j'en crée une
copie parce que j'étais toujours accès à
la photo après je voulais envoyer
donc c'est pas grave quand il s'agit
d'une photo mais si je reprends mon
billet que je vous donne 10 euros c'est
assez important que j'ai plus les 10
euros après parce que sinon c'est un peu
le principe même de l'argent qui tombe
en miettes
donc ça on pouvait pas faire avant et la
bloque chaîne qu'est ce qu'elle va faire
elle va créer la propriété numérique et
la confiance dans un milieu hostile sans
intermédiaire et grâce à cela vous
pouvez changer de la valeur sur internet
alors la valeur
on l'a dit ça peut être de la monnaie
mais ça peut être plein d'autres choses
ça peut être des titres des certificats
d actions etc etc donc vous paie un
petit florilège d'application de la blog
shane alors y'a bitcoin on l'a vu mais
je vous prends un cas d'usagé très
simple
le les fameuses rémittente les rémy les
remises par don coût du philippin qui
travaille aux états unis qui envoie de
l'argent à sa famille etc
aujourd'hui fait quoi ils passent par
western union western union c'est ça lui
prend quatre jours et ça lui prend 10%
bon bitcoin dix minutes 5 centimes pour
entretenir le réseau
à partir de là la comparaison les fêtes
on passe à autre chose
le scribe certifié de manière
indépendante et pair à pair
décentralisée delà de la propriété
intellectuelle transactive anti-grippe a
renoncé à new york
c'est de l' échange d'énergie en pair à
pair passait plus par l'intermédiaire
stored adieu les fermes de serveurs de
microsoft ou google parce que vous
pouvez faire du cloud décentralisée plus
personne pour contrôler vos données je
termine avec beats landes rapidement par
exemple c'est au ghana eh bien on part
du principe que l'on n'a pas très
confiance dans le gouvernement ghanéen
pour tenir un cadastre donc de les
répertorier les propriétés géographique
de chacun et ben on va le faire passer
par là bloqué parce qu'on n'a pas besoin
de confiance n'a pas besoin
d'intermédiaire
donc tout ça finalement ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que les blocs chaîne
s'est récupéré le contrôle sur ses
données sur son argent sur sa vie de
manière générale et en fait je termine
de manière un peu lyrique mais qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire que pour
la première fois depuis très longtemps
on remet en cause des modèles de
confiance qui ont existé depuis des
siècles les banques les notaires les
gouvernements etc
là on commence à dire effet finalement
ce n'est peut-être pas si utile que ça
ces gens là pour la première fois dans
l'histoire on se dit je préfère faire
confiance faire confiance la notion est
très importante à des algorithmes plutôt
qu'à des humains et là je vous pose la
question est-ce vraiment ça
l'émancipation numérique
merci
[Applaudissements]